early years aspiring actress yeah
getting started new york tough going
right it was awful like i was um
i was so unemployed that the
that the unemployment office turned me
down like i like is that true yes i was
really unemployed and so at the time um
like i was just like embarrassed to be
myself like you know when you just wake
up in the morning you're like oh i'm
like embarrassed right um
so like you know you know how much you i
do know that fear
i knew what you're talking even when my
agent would call me i was embarrassed
for him that he represented me you just
couldn't get worse it was awful so ever
and i had like two auditions a year so
every audition meant the world sure so i
got this audition for royal pains and so
this is like my life i get a call back
amazing
and so it's my life so i go to the hair
salon the night before to like get a
blowout and like get my nails done and i
even got my vagina waxed the night
before like i just wanted to be like
fresh for the audition
so
um
so
there's a place where you can get a mold
made
oh yeah we'll talk later about it
so you're there
and my boyfriend at the time calls me
and i don't pick up because i'm getting
my hair done so he calls again and i'm
like
i answer because i'm like what's
happening so he called i'm like hello
and he's like there's a fire in the
building like the apartment was on fire
it's on fire yeah yes and i he it was
true i heard like firemen in the
background so he's like quickly what do
you want me to retrieve from for from
the house like do you want what do you
want i'm thinking like what do you do
like my hard drive like i don't know but
then i remembered and i don't know if
this is superstitious but i like to wear
the same outfit on the callback as i do
to the original audition right and i had
the call back the next day
so i was like this is very important i'm
like go in the closet and get my beige
push-up bra my black and white flowy
skirt and my pink top and he's like are
you kidding me i'm getting my passport
and my social security card
and i was like nick this audition is all
we have in life of the house the house
goes and flames so he's like fine
he doesn't sound like that i don't like
that's just like the essence that's the
brawny paper towel guy yeah
so then he doesn't the next day the
landlord because i'm i was in queens she
was like oh you have a good boyfriend
like he was holding you black pumps
outside with the firemen and i'm like
yeah he's cool so anyway i go to the
audition i go to the audition in the
outfit and the first thing the producers
say is they compliment my outfit so i'm
like well
i went through flames for this outfit i
told the story right they loved it i
booked the job wow and now so i was
convinced i booked the role not because
of my acting because i told this story
right so
so on the next audition i'm like you
know what
let me just tell the story again
i booked that job too
so i'm like
i'm no longer embarrassed to be me i
feel good about life like i start
telling the story every time at
auditions no i just felt like it was the
magic secret like to everything sure so
it changed my life so i started telling
the story everywhere i go
then i go into another edition i won't
say the show because i don't want to
like get in trouble but i go down and
audition for another show that was big
at the time and i go and i tell the
story and like it gets
like no one's laughing it's really
embarrassing so the next day my manager
calls and he's like it looks like
something
backfired
i'm like what do you mean because i
never told him i was telling this story
because i knew he'd tell me not to and i
don't like when people tell me not to do
things
so
um so i'm like what do you mean he's
like well apparently he's like people
talk heather you've been telling the
same story for a whole year
and um the producer thought it was just
awful and you kept people waiting anyway
you're blacklisted from ever auditioning
for this show
but then he said i believe in you and
even though you're probably gonna go
back to trying to collect unemployment i
think you'll tell this story on your
first talk show oh that's nice and here
you are